it's a long wait in an uncomfortable
chair
but they've decided today is the day
mariama is receiving the vaccine despite
her earlier reservations
i didn't trust the vaccine at first
that's why i didn't take it
when i saw my parents were vaccinated
and that everything went well for them
i decided to get the shot vaccination
points are getting closer to people's
homes
near the local mosque or sports stadium
hundreds of thousands of doses arrived
in senegal this week
it's important to note that this
strategy which is a proximity strategy
allows us to bring the vaccine close to
the population
it will allow us to considerably
accelerate our rollout
because we know today that the pandemic
is gaining ground and we must move
faster than the delta variant
the delta variant is fueling a third
wave and more senegalese see the writing
on the wall
the pandemic is in their neighborhood
nearly one million people have been
vaccinated
but there aren't enough doses to go
round and millions more are needed
everyone is here we're moving now
because before we used to say it was for
the elderly
but now we see 13 year old kids getting
sick
we see younger people in their 20s dying
it's a total panic now
hospitals in dakar are overflowing with
new arrivals
the ministry of health says its
facilities are already operating at 100
capacity for severe and critical
patients meaning every bed with oxygen
available
is taken the head of infectious diseases
at fan hospital says it's just the tip
of the iceberg
to tell you the truth the situation is
catastrophic
we are a bit overwhelmed doctors would
like to take care of the patients but
the main issue is the lack of equipment
and available places
when family members began to fall ill
idrisa returned to senegal
only to begin counting the number of
loved ones lost
this time a cousin only 40 years old
i was in a cemetery yesterday and one
day alone others usually
bury about three four people yesterday
alone they buried 35 people so
there is something going on it's the
world crisis i'm sorry that
my people here they kind of figured it
out a little bit too late i wish they
would have figured out a little bit
sooner
but now we're just trying to catch up
less than two percent of the senegalese
population has been fully vaccinated
and with hospitals overwhelmed doses are
in high demand
andrew chappelle al jazeera